[Music]
a dry erase board is a non-permanent
surface most commonly used in
professional or classroom environments
you simply write on the board with a dry
erase marker and use a specialized cloth
to wipe away the markings these
effective tools are an easy way to get
your message across dry erase boards are
also known as whiteboards the board's
why perfectly clean due to its
non-porous surface and the dry erase ink
dry erase it contains release agents
which prevent the pigments from
permanently adhering to the surface
green and black dry erase boards can
also be used as chalk boards while gray
and low gloss white double as projection
boards the surface material is a
porcelain coated steel sheet flexible
enough to be rolled up but also
pressure-sensitive to start the roll is
mounted on a cutting machine a
technician programs the machine to cut
the roll to a specific length based on
the board's dimensions workers verify
the length and check that the piece is
square the surface material will be
applied to one of seven types of
substrate ranging from cardboard to
medium density fiberboard known as MDF
the next step is to cut the large sheet
of substrate in this case MDF into board
sized pieces another technician enters
the length and width into the cutting
machine
once complete the machine ejects the
substrate which has now cut to the exact
size of the board next the substrate is
put through a hot glue machine the
machine applies polyurethane adhesive to
what will be the back of the dry erase
board as the substrate exits a sheet of
foil is applied to the glued surface the
foil prevents moisture from entering
which would warp the substrate the board
moves through two steel rollers which
flatten the foil and press out any
trapped air next the surface material is
applied to the other side of the
substrate a craftswoman uses an air hose
to clear away any dust from the side of
the board once cleaned the board goes
through the glue machine the porcelain
steel sheet is placed on the glued
surface technicians work carefully to
ensure they don't touch the
pressure-sensitive surface with their
fingers then the board moves through the
steel rollers to press the porcelain
steel flat and remove any trapped air
once 50 boards are stacked technicians
put them in a press for half an hour
until the glue cures in another part of
the factory a machine cuts material to
create the board's frame it punches
v-shaped notches in the lengths of
aluminum trim the trim bends at each
notch to form a wraparound frame some
boards come with a marker tray that runs
along the bottom to make these trays a
technician cuts board length pieces from
a piece of l-shaped metal trim since the
tray ends are sharp a technician
attaches plastic covers for protection
he secures the plastic end covers with
screws on both ends of the part
[Music]
meanwhile technicians peel off the
protective film covering the writing
surface then they flip over the board to
assemble the parts from the back this
model doesn't have the traditional
wraparound frame instead it has a frame
comprised of four straight C shaped
pieces that fit over the board's edges
to add stability technicians attach
screws through the trim into the
substrate once assembly is complete the
dry erase board is placed into a box
ready to be shipped to a business or
classroom near you